en rusia las cifras de coronavirus han
vuelto a pulverizar récords el número de
muertes por la pandemia en un solo día
ha superado por primera vez el millar de
personas hay 33 mil nuevos casos cada
día la mayor cifra de infecciones en un
solo día desde que comenzó la pandemia
en total se han registrado casi 8
millones de casos de esta enfermedad en
rusia desde que comenzó la crisis ya
murieron por coronavirus aquí 222 mil
personas el kremlin ha culpado del
creciente número de muertes a la lenta
campaña de vacunación de rusia porque el
problema es que muchos rusos son
escépticos con respecto a las vacunas
sobre todo con respecto a las vacunas
rusas las autoridades ahora están
tratando de agilizar la detección con
análisis gratuitos en ciudades como
moscú pero parece inevitable volver a
tener que tomar restricciones aquí por
ejemplo el mismo poco los cepi de la pcr
negativa o el certificado de vacunación
para asistir a algunos eventos son
museos y el foro cultural de sant
petersburgo ha tenido que ser suspendido
de nuevo se vuelve a poner sobre la mesa
la posibilidad de exigir códigos qr esta
vez para poder comprar alcohol una
medida que puede ser muy popular entre
muchos rusos